good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Thursday how's
everyone doing Jax how you turn I'm
doing good it's the first Thursday in
May do you know what that means that's a
good question what does that mean the
new episode of the redhead oh LOL has
dropped and I'm really excited I
actually was just thinking about like oh
I need to promote the redheads and I
almost started this episode welcome back
redheads to another episode of the
redheads book club that's kind of like
our iconic intro yeah and you always say
it I always say it is there any inviting
amongst a group like Jax I want to do
the intro no because if you want to do
the intro here's another list of things
that you now need to do right anyone's
welcome to do it yeah yeah they all we
have a we have a system yeah I feel like
you've governed the redheads with an
iron fist yeah and everybody I think
everybody likes the way things are run I
think we all like the way things are run
everyone's pleased with the way things
are going yeah and you can hear how
things are going in the new episode that
just dropped you look adorable today is
this this sweater which belongs to me
um is this like a sort of symbolic
gesture you know you're wearing the
folklore sweatshirt sweater cardigan
thing and you know this is our last
episode before I head to Nashville there
is an episode tomorrow you guys it's
just Audio Only and um I'm gonna be in
Nashville so yes the timing of me
wearing this sweater says I support you
in your journey and I'm wearing this as
a symbol of the eras tour I didn't
conceive of it that way when I asked you
to borrow it I just like wanted to
borrow a cardigan and I was like oh I
know she has the cardigan and that would
be easy for her you know if I just said
can I borrow a cardigan you would be so
good which one so I said this cardigan
and it's really really ugly oh no it's
so ugly we need to get snitch on here
there was like such positive tale of
Rhymes when she was here no I have
positive Taylor Vibes we have a lot of
Taylor talk today plus you're going to
the aerostore plus she's our first story
and our biggest story but this cardigan
is ugly and now that she's out say it
again say it again the cardigan I
brought from home for you keep calling
my [__] our homemade again keep holding
my [__] ugly [__] now that she's out of
folklore like can we talk about how ugly
it was Jackie was not into the folklore
aesthetic I will say it wasn't my
personal Vibe it's very like fall you
know upstairs
plaid plaid could go either it's not my
personal aesthetic but it was right for
the moment especially like in Kobe like
that's what everyone was wearing it was
but like she went a little too hard with
it she took it a little too far well
you'll be pleased to know I know you
haven't like seen what the arrow store
is but like when she does her era for
folklore and Evermore it's not she's
Glam whims it's Glam Whimsical fairy
witch right because she even she knows
she wouldn't be caught dead in this
[__] cardigan I will say like now
that we're out of it like the curly
bangs were not my favorite I can say
that I'm a mature things you didn't like
that they're curly swirly dirty bangs
were not my favorite yeah but I'm not
gonna poo poo this cardigan that is
clothing me today literally I'm sure it
looks horrible on the show gorgeous even
like when I wore the Fendi skims
cardigan which like not to pimp women
against each other but like that's a
nicer cardigan oh yeah I mean it's Cindy
it was literally two thousand dollars
and you're wearing a 35 sweater right
right you could tell uh [__] and it
shows Jackie's just wearing my clothes
which I love to you know share and
you're just [__] on them I don't
feel like I'm [__] on you with this
cardigan though and I've really been
like such a champion of your wardrobe
recently she has I literally was at
Jackie I went shopping yesterday for the
era's tour I'm now I know I said it
earlier in the week like I wasn't ready
because I was dead from Stagecoach I'm
ready now you know I'm all packed my
flight tonight you just needed three
days that's your turnaround time yeah I
charge up some people take like they
need 30 minutes to themselves I need
three whole days at home to charge up
yeah and I'm charged and you're charged
and Jackie was so helpful I got like
some cute outfits for the hours for
we're also having a spritz event so I
have like a busy weekend in Nashville so
it's like a big weekend to be you know
me in Nashville why you because it's
actually a big weekend to be a few
people one because I'm going to eras and
it's like the world is currently
revolving around me and you can't tell
me otherwise two Spritz is finally
launching in Nashville this week we are
now being sold in a bunch of
establishment if you go to spritz.com
and use a store locator you can find all
the different like liquor stores and
bars and such and we're like adding new
ones every day but a part of our big
lunch is something so exciting that I've
been wanting to tell everyone we have
our first Ambassador so and Ambassador
our brand ambassador in Nashville when
we were thinking you know who could we
get who could it be there was really
only one name on everybody's lips tips
of everyone's tongue man in Ford Shannon
Ford is our newsprits ambassador so
she's going to be all over Nashville
like promoting Spritz she's the face of
Spritz all over but specifically in
Nashville so we're hosting an event for
her to celebrate and I got like a really
spritzy dress that's like orange and
pink and like so Shannon and I sent it
to Shannon I was like I don't want to
upstage you this is like you're a big
night and she's like [__] ugly you're
so ugly you can never upstage me that's
not what she said but like there was a
subtext she's like no you're fine I'm
like yeah I know I'm fine yeah
um so that was great and it's just gonna
be a great week and I'm so excited about
Chad and I'm so excited about sports and
I'm so excited about Taylor like we got
like a big party bus we're gonna fill it
with Spritz and we're gonna be the most
annoying people possible I'm gonna I
think Vlog for patreon great and I got
like a new camera you know all the kids
are I forgot to tell you Sony that
Canon's posting let me tell you everyone
is using these cameras yes including our
younger sister Margo went on a little
snap with a bunch of um her
Satchel Satchel is and that's so on
brand for Satchel too it's like a Canon
g7x camera yeah so Margaret went on like
a trip with a bunch of her influencer
friends they were all taking uh pictures
on this camera so Margaret the camera
now everyone's using the camera and I
was going through my stuff getting my
podcast equipment ready for Stagecoach
and I have like this corner of my room
with just like my Tech Supplies and I
forgot I literally have that camera when
we were building your studio I bought a
bunch of different cameras to like see
what would be good for patreon what
would be good whatever and it was too I
had like scratched up this one that I
wanted to return and I couldn't return
it I was like you know maybe I'll keep
it for patreon and stuff and it was a
Canon g7x like I was so ahead of the
time this was like over almost a year
ago wow so I have that I'm gonna make
like premium Vlog quality [__] I'm
excited yeah so it's like a reality show
I want like confessionals from all the
people going like Dana you know what is
she feeling everyone maybe if everyone
could like make a little video of
themselves getting ready I know
everyone's like staying in different
places yeah so like maybe everyone could
contribute that would be great and that
would make me it would be for me like to
feel like I'm there I love that for you
yeah
um so it's never a bad time to be a
patreon member like we're going to
Topgolf we have so many fun things I'm I
need to charge like I need to take it
easy to day and each ticket is tomorrow
I need to charge up because it's going
to be one hell of a weekend yeah I'm
excited I'm absolutely devastated that
you're not coming I understand why
you're not but like it's genuinely like
an uncool thing of you to do yeah it's
just too much for me of course course so
but it's uncool I know but I can't even
see myself there at this point I know
you know I know like what would I wear I
mean I'm not you would wear the card and
I'm not even pregnant and I'm like what
am I wearing yeah but your outfit is
really good I hope you're feeling really
good about it I am feeling good I did
order some things to ship to my hotel I
got this very cool thing too much to
ship things shipping and things to which
and I might change up the shirt but I
have a good like shirt just in case you
know but I got a very cool like very
lover error skirt okay okay cool yeah
what what what's with the face no I'm
just until I see it like of course I
just I need to see it I need to see
these things in which to say and I'm
wondering like if I were going not
pregnancy it's like not as
not as many options but like whatever I
would have gone for so let me tell you
how like when I first like knew I was
gonna be going to this concert before I
even had tickets I'm like I'm gonna
dress up as an era me and Margo even
thought about dressing up as Taylor and
Selena and those matching black and
white outfits when Selena came on to
sing can't keep my hand like those
studded but then I was like all right I
need to calm down
um like I was gonna go really specific
like I even I bought a gold Fearless
dress that looked so [__] ugly on me
Beachside bunny can't return never
ordering from you again what is this
these places you can't return I've been
ordering them no that you'll want to
return I've been ordering from like a
bunch of like basically like like
influencer shops like Beachside bunny
12th tribe you can't return like I'm the
type of [__] I will order so much up
and I'll keep a lot of it but I can't
keep everything so you can't shop at
those websites I didn't know I didn't
even occur to me to look yeah who
doesn't have [__] returns that's
literally like stalinism it's getting
Stalin yeah right yeah he's definitely
had a bad return policy and he
definitely give you a label or no
exchanges no no oh yeah you can return
it for store credit uh your website
sucks why the [__] would I want to store
credit so I was gonna be like really
Niche and it gets hard and you just like
want to dress in like sparkles you know
yeah Sparkles are easy maybe when I go
in New York since like I'm feeling so
rushed now I'll be more methodical with
like a full Recreation oh because you're
going in New York too yeah here's an
idea that like I don't think is like the
right idea but just an idea that can't
throw it out because you're going with
like a really big girl gang like if you
all dress like bad blood music video the
whole box yeah I mean thanks for that
idea the day we leave I can't really
stress how entirely helpful that is but
is that a good idea yeah of course we're
gonna be like sick tick tocks where we
all pretended to be like Zendaya and
yeah Olivia Benson thanks so much [__]
like oh my god well
at least you're not that song sucks I
actually she does perform that song
actually yeah she doesn't I'm sure she
does a good version of it and she does
like a short one perfect yeah because
there's like a bunch of eras like we
just got reputation tour we just got
1989 we've never seen folklore Evermore
a lot of us weren't there for debut or
you know so she does a bridge like 1989
she does like Shake It Off Bad Blood
like the songs everybody hates and she
does them really short like I love that
yeah so that's like a good time to go to
the bathroom yeah
okay cool yeah so again thank you
so generous
nobody asked me like [__]
Lego Universal like knowledge exactly
the best ideas like you need like I
literally did a podcast yesterday and
somebody was like asking me like how do
you guys do this and I'm like Jackie the
whole podcast I was like well Jackie did
that can you share what podcast you did
I don't know I don't know when does it
come out it doesn't come out for a few
weeks right and I don't know it's not
like anything crazy it's not Howard
Stern you know like yeah yeah it's a
really good I'll give a clue it's a
really good podcast of like a very
popular influencer who loves the toast
who we've recently become friendly with
can't wait to listen yeah it was good
but she was just like she's new to
podcasting she was asking so many
questions about like well what did you
do here and how do you know about this
I'm like well Jackie said that and then
Jackie did that and yeah maybe you
should have Jackie on that's so sweet
well if you're going to aerosaur with a
big girl group then is a good idea for
you yeah because I haven't seen anyone
do that no me neither yeah I wonder what
it means to Taylor like how moved she
must be by the fact that like everybody
is showing up and showing out for her
like people go to concert shows the
theater they were merch yeah
at best they look like they wear sweats
everyone's biker shorts t-shirt like
which that's just how people dress But
like everyone just decided to be Black
Tie yeah for Taylor Swift and it must be
like so flattering flattering for her
and I just I wonder what it means to her
yeah either people are dressing up to
the nines like sequins Black Tie or
people are getting so creative with like
costumes like I saw they keep it on the
ground yes I saw two girls dressed up as
um fire
and they were holding blue paint brushes
did it was two girls did the Twin Flame
Blues paint you blue looks so Niche and
it's so funny yeah like it's so
flattering you're right yeah so I I'm
sure she like looks around already
thousands of people there everybody
singing every lyric to every song and
they came out and they dressed up for
her like they all went to dry bar they
all got their makeup done yeah and then
they all like put thought and Care into
their outfits and like wore dresses and
seamless even when the sweats are more
comfortable yeah of course and like I
was thinking like it's a three-hour
concert I want to like pop my [__]
dance I would love to wear just like
athleisure and sneakers actually I'm
wearing sneakers because I need to know
my limits
um and how much more fun I would
probably have if I was like actually
comfortable but I would never do that to
Taylor no I think you'll have more fun
being dressed up honestly yeah like
taking pictures I'm so excited I and I
just want to prepare everyone like my
stories will be so annoying like they
will be I think it's good I think it's
what we need to see good because it's
the one you got do you have your tissues
over there I could just like use a
little sniffle I love tissues it's like
a new thing I've kind of discovered
through Jackie of course that like
tissues exist and if you have like a
little snot bubble or something or like
a runny nose like you don't have to use
your sleeve and you don't have to use a
paper towel you don't have to keep
snorting up right you can give a little
dab with a nice soft tissue you can use
a tissue that's like it's life-changing
it's a life-changing Discovery yeah you
were like we need tissues for the studio
I'm like tashes and you're so right yeah
add it to the list add it to the list
well thank you for the tissue
it's a pleasure we've got a great show
yeah we do we've got stories we've got
Vanderpump Rules we have Vanderpump
Rules do you watch Watch What Happens
Live I did I did turn off maybe with
like 10 minutes left because honestly
analy Ashford was annoying the [__] out
of me I liked her enthusiasm me too it's
nice when someone and they've been doing
that like pairing every Wednesdays watch
Robin's eye with somebody who like gets
it and it's not just like a celebrity
who just has something to promote yeah
and a celebrity who would be pissed at
the whole time we're talking about
Vanderpump Rules you're talking to like
you know a relative nobody but not in
this yeah circumstance yeah so I did
watch that and we're gonna recap it in
addition to the Fast Five and just a
reminder tomorrow's episode I'm bringing
all my equipment with me I will be doing
my podcast from Nashville I'll be
simmering in a spray tan that Shannon
will will you know Shannon has like a
whole ass I know is she gonna spray you
yeah wow and that's intimate oh she's
she literally nothing is more intimate
after what we've been through this
weekend because when we got to the house
like I was sick and everyone was like
Claudia like you can take the master I'm
like thank you so much but the bathroom
was like literally too big for one
person so everyone like makeup and hair
and like shower station was my bathroom
um and so like me Margo and Shannon
basically like we all shower in front of
each other like like there's nothing
Shannon has seen that has hasn't already
been seen but she is it's actually so
smart and the last time I was in
Nashville for my show she did it for me
too and I actually looked so beautiful
it's so smart she's like a full-blown
professional airbrush machine that she
keeps and she uses her guest bathroom as
like the shower as the booth and she's
like yeah and then she you know I was
like will you spray me and she's like
yeah come over either Thursday night or
Friday morning she's like wait no I'll
pick you up from the airport and then
take you inspire and then drop you off
at your hotel can you believe she offer
to pick me up at the airport that's so
kind that's real friendship I honestly
look I feel like I'm not gonna make her
like I actually feel bad
friendship she's such a friend I know
she's such a [__] real one I love
that [__]
yeah
um so I'm just excited I'm really I'm
I'm so sad you're not coming don't worry
about me enjoy yourself you won't even
have a thought about me send lots of
pics and we can't wait for the recap on
Monday I know I mean I'm back in studio
Monday it's gonna be great
so with that with that in two should we
yeah I agree the fast five stories that
you need to know today and I'm so
excited we have a new sponsor for a show
that I'm quaking over so Netflix is
sponsoring today's episode telling us
about their new show Queen Charlotte a
Bridgerton story so it's centered on
Queen Charlotte who we know from
Bridgerton it's like her origin story
it's a prequel it's about her rise to
prominence and power this Bridgerton
verse prequel tells the story of how the
young Queen's marriage to King George
sparked both a great love story and a
societal shift creating the world of the
ton inherited by the characters in
Bridgerton so not only do we get Queen
Charlotte's origin story we see so many
characters that we know Angela Danbury
yes Mrs Bridgerton the Bridgerton mom so
it's a story about how young Charlotte
young Agatha Danbury and young Violet
Bridgerton came to be the Beloved and
revered characters that they are in
bergerton you learn how they found their
place in power all while navigating
their personal passions and politics it
is of course written by Shonda Rhimes
and she's also the executive producer so
you know it's going to be good while the
characters are arm positions of power
behind closed doors they are as
vulnerable as the next person this
series explores the struggles to balance
their personal life alongside their Duty
the love between Queen Charlotte and
King George is the love story to inspire
all love stories the kind of love that
the entire ton aspires to for themselves
it's the myth that has ever that has set
everything the series has all the
elements of Bridgeton audiences that
they love you know like the sex the
steamy Romance the Scandal the ton of
course and the chemistry between young
Queen Charlotte and young King George is
steamy so it's romantic it's sexy it's
scandalous it's glamorous it's relatable
it's daring and it's authentic and you
can watch it now on Netflix the premiere
today May 4th people are already loving
it it's only available on Netflix you
can watch it now and I am so excited
well I know what I'll be doing this
weekend yes today's episode is also
brought to you by honey love the reviews
are in and honey love came out on top
for the best wedding day shapewear also
the best eras shapewear and I literally
was thinking about canceling my trip
last night I don't know if you saw my
Instagram story I could not find my
honey love shapewear because I just done
laundry I'm like where did I put it I
actually certainly left it in like the
bottom of the laundry bin but it was
clean it was like a whole thing but
basically all that to say like you can't
go anywhere without your shapewear so
whether you're a bride a guest or you're
just looking for an everyday fit at a
wedding Honey Love Is Your go-to for all
things shapewear they have
revolutionized compression technology so
you no longer have to feel like you're
suffocating while wearing effective
shapewear you'll immediately feel and
see the difference and of course we have
an exclusive offer for our listeners get
20 off your entire order with code
toast20 at honeylove.com so I got so
many messages actually after our last
honey love read people being like thank
you for like the the Revelation that is
honey love I'm going to a wedding I'm
going to an event I have whatever and
it's really changing people's lives
because you shouldn't have to sacrifice
sacrifice your oxygen just to you know
have sneeze
smooth snatched lines when you're
wearing a dress and honey love
understands that so they're super power
short is helping ladies ever wear sculpt
and smooth from stomach to thigh by just
offering you the perfect amount of
compression you don't have to worry
about it rolling down thanks to their
flexible boning that's hidden in the
seams we've all been here struggling to
take off a tight piece of shapewear
while you're you know trying to use the
bathroom at the at the event but their
shapewear has 100 cotton gusset so you
can skip the extra undies plus it is a
convenient opening in the panty area for
super easy bathroom access treat
yourself to the best shape around the
market toasters are loving it and save
20 off at honeylove.com when you use
code toast20 that's code
t-o-a-s-t-20 at honeylove.com thank you
Claudia you're welcome Jackie our first
story back to Taylor Taylor Swift is
dating the 1975's Matt Healy after her
split with Joe Alwyn reports the Sun and
everybody else is following suit Daily
Mail that Taylor has reportedly found
herself another London boy she is now
dating the 1975 front man Matt Healy a
source says it's super early days but it
feels right they first dated very
briefly almost 10 years ago but the
timings just didn't work out although
Joe and Taylor's breakup was announced
last month The Insider claimed they
broke up in February so there's
absolutely no crossover in fact fact the
new couple is reportedly ready to go
public with their romance this weekend
you're saying he's bringing up Swift's
upcoming era's tour in Nashville listen
I would love for all of this to be true
and I'll get into the reasoning why but
one thing about Taylor is like we
literally she's never she's we've never
bested Her Like She's always there's no
way like a surprise guest has been
leaked that no but not necessarily
surprise guests but maybe he's going to
the show with her maybe they're gonna go
step out to dinner in Nashville no
matter I have to make dinner
reservations I don't think that if they
are dating that she's gonna now like put
in front and center at her show yeah
that's fair I think more so that they
will be spotted together in Nashville
well
also they're reporting that unlike
Taylor's relationship with Joe which was
extremely private The Source said that
the new couple wants to own this romance
and not hide it away okay so let's take
two different Lanes here let's talk
about the this being true let's say this
is true
so here for it Taylor being like a
public relationship with another star
I've recently fallen into 1975 Tick Tock
and like I totally understand like the
Matty Healy thing he's like this
tortured artist he's really talented but
he's kind of crazy he like makes out
with fans and he says crazy [__] and
he's always chain smoking cigarettes and
he's always drunk like I love that for
her her going from like this really
stable Almost Boring relationship with
Joe to like chaos I think that's exactly
what she needs if true what I don't know
that doesn't sound like great I didn't
know it's fun like it's a rebound I feel
like this isn't a rebound
by the way I pride myself on knowing
everything about Taylor I did not know
that she had previously dated him albeit
like a short brief romance like I think
it was Italian it was Italians a dallian
like maybe even a text message sort of
you know like maybe an attempted Meetup
sort of thing a dalliance Italians I'm
so glad I hope not spontaneously well
I also saw a headline that as of a few
months ago he stopped kissing fans at
his shows yes which would signal his
love and respect for Miss Swift right
like a monogamous moment yeah but I
didn't know he was like a crazy rock
star type I thought he was like you
talked about him a few months ago on the
toast that he's like you know everybody
was loving him the 1975 is so good and
he they are so good front man but I
didn't know he was a party boy oh he's
nuts bad boy if you watch any footage of
him on stage he's so psychotic he's so
talented and it never really gets in the
way of his performances but he's like
always drinking always smoking
cigarettes like always like slurring
like he's nuts but I think it really is
like an act almost I don't know he's
very like tortured artist Vibe I don't
I'm not educated enough on the 1975 yet
I'm getting there to know like what who
who's the real mad Haley but he's like
crazy okay so would you say like this
would be it for her no no no no no no no
no no I was feeling like this was it for
her no because they made it seem that
way like you know it was wrong place
right time wrong time right person kind
of thing all those years ago and now
they're both in different places I don't
think that this is like it but it's
definitely fun because oh and like
another clue now in hindsight before
Eris started Taylor
um was brought out to a 1975 show and
she sang Auntie right
so now we're like looking back we're
like oh for sure they were bugging back
you know back in the day and the source
says they were introduced by Jack
Antonoff right which makes sense I feel
like everyone Taylor meets in her life
is introduced to her by Jack Angeles
because he just knows everyone yeah
so so do you believe it no
no no like nothing about Taylor that's
actually true we know you know like
she's so she really is like this Vault I
kind of believe it I'm so I want to
believe it but I don't know like them
saying they're gonna like be out and
about like if okay if she's actually out
and about with Matt Healy and Nashville
like then everything in this article is
true you know well it doesn't mean that
everything is true I don't know I just
the Sun
but it's British I know but like I think
I don't understand the landscape of
British tabloids but and everybody else
is picking it up yeah because once once
person one once one Outlet picks it up
all the other outlets can pick it up
without having like the blame placed on
that yes but not when it's absolute
nonsense yeah I mean I'm so here for it
like and there was a dumwa tip that they
were set up by Jack Antonoff yes and
Dumont had posted uh her podcast like a
a sneak peek of her podcast that I think
drops today with this clue in it right
before the sun came out
so
two two things things are adding yeah
I'm trepidatious of course but I'm
optimistic I'm here for it it makes a
lot of sense
you would like the 1975 it's like sooner
I can never understand what the [__]
they're saying but it's like
you know look that's the vibe and it's
good sounds really good it is
like chocolate I only know the word
chocolate
so it's like it's like happy music like
you know yeah you love it yeah it's cute
so
what does this mean where do we go I
don't know but I feel good knowing like
able to make the story about me like I
will be in Nashville I'll tell you guys
everything you'll let us know what you
see and I will be like hitting up all
the hot spots just to you know look
around corners dark hallways seeing if I
see them yeah
I think that this makes a lot of sense
for us her next relationship like she's
still like it's a little bit similar to
Joe but also very different she really
does love a British boy you know she
loves a London boy is nice and Brixton
what like that didn't change just
because like her and Joe changed yeah
but like really all of her boyfriends
like Harry Tom Hiddleston Joe
what other Brits was she linked to all
no not all but like a lot recently
they're also just like a lot of
boyfriends don't be that Jackie no I'm
not saying in a negative way don't I'm
literally don't do it I'm not don't do
but I'm not saying it in a derogatory
way it's just like the volume there's a
lot to choose from which I love that for
her and also like she's been off the
market for a few years yes and now we're
getting like this Taylor about like
eligible tailor back no and I also I
find it very exciting and I'm not like
there's no shade in anything that I'm
saying like what else the [__] should
she be doing no she's been famous for 15
years and like a gorgeous single girl
what the [__] should she be no and I
feel like we're like right now the
tailor that we have is like the best
version of Taylor I feel like she's like
probably the happiest she's ever been
she's so confident I feel like for a lot
of years she like struggled with like
the fame and I feel like she's at a good
place now so whoever like I feel like
now she's gonna be like attracting that
energy and I that's what I said I don't
think you were on the toes I think maybe
it was Margo like when we were
dissecting the breakup everyone was like
Chris falling I'm like no [__] like I
love a single like I lived for Taylor's
boyfriend's era like I've been kind of
bored
but boring is it's good no of course
like she has to make a life for herself
but I'm just I'm commenting merely as a
spectator and had you seen the rumor
before that she was dating that F1
driver yes and he was like making tick
there was like a very baseless small I
didn't even hear it rumor that she was
dating this F1 driver then he started
making all these tick tocks using her
music and people were like it means it's
true and I'm like no this guy's just
[__] thirsty and the more and he's
made multiple tick tocks the more he
makes the less valid this rumor is and I
don't even know this man but I think
he's a thirsty loser now and I'm sure
Taylor does too I'm sure Taylor doesn't
know this man
literally I am sorry to this man yeah
okay so hopefully there's more where
this came from yeah I will say like on a
looks level I don't think they're equal
you know I like to
you know Taylor's like the most
beautiful woman ever and he's like you
know but that's the thing it's like
tortured artists who are a little bit
ugly like people think they're hot like
it's not traditionally gorgeous handsome
you know he's not like
Jake Johnson but I think she's beyond
that you know yeah looking into their
soul looks are so like would you say Joe
is handsome as her
no but I think some people I think some
people find Joe extremely handsome I
don't say Tom Hiddleston
yeah he's handsome he is he's a
classically handsome he is yeah
to me he's no more or less handsome than
Matt Healy no I think he's more handsome
let me get a nice photo of him I love
like judging other men's looks and like
calling them ugly it's my favorite thing
no Tom Hiddleston is very classically
handsome so is Joe
let me look again yeah yeah okay like
that's a bad pig
no okay
he's just like really not photogenic and
this long hair era he was in is not cute
it's like I have to Google pictures of
all these men because like I I don't
know whether or not they're handsome
because I don't look at them
um okay I'm sorry I look through that
Tom Hiddleston is handsome I I stand by
what I said like so there are some ugly
pictures of him on the internet though I
mean relatable
relatable
okay well are you ready to move on from
this like like no today I don't think
I'll ever be ready but yes for the sake
of you know the memory cards right I'm
I'm ready
our next story Jackson Mahomes brother
of Patrick Mahomes is now cousin of
Austin cousin of Austin Mahomes is now
out on bond following aggravated sexual
battery accusation so yesterday it was
reported that Jackson Mahomes was
arrested on charges of aggravated sexual
battery uh this was in connection with
the um incident that we described a few
weeks ago of him at a bar was that a few
weeks ago it does feel like a few months
a few weeks could be a few months no it
wasn't like two to three weeks it was
definitely like a month or two I feel
like it was actually three to four
months like everything I know I know
it's attorney I know I know
um so the local news channel captured
footage of him walking to his car from
the Johnson County Detention Center
according to the outlet he was charged
with three felony counts of aggravated
sexual battery and a misdemeanor count
of battery uh he was out on a 100
000 Bond and his arrest stems from the
alleged incident at a local restaurant
in late February okay late February what
is it early May
it's a couple it's it's up it's two
months right February March March to
April it's like 10 weeks so that's more
than a couple weeks yeah so we're both
wrong in the middle right this is what
this is what was right right
um so what's so unique about the
situation I feel like a lot of times
like you know we report on celebrities
like even that Jonathan Majors thing
that like kind of is not going away have
you seen that he's been dropped by like
his like there's I think there's more
stuff coming out it's always like he
said she said like we do believe this
whole thing is captured on footage on
camera the footage of it is so
disgusting like he did that [__] and
good good he got arrested good good yeah
so no one's Above the Law [__] no it's
just so weird like you know Patrick is
this like American Icon
I got to talk about him there did he win
the Super Bowl yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Travis he won the Super Bowl like it's
this difference is so Stark and I'm sure
he's like supporting his brother during
this time because he's been very
supportive of his brother but it's so
weird yeah
it's it's not good he needs to get his
act together he needs to get it like
because clearly everything that like has
happened to Jackson Mahomes is a
byproduct of like him thinking he's the
[__] Untouchable yeah when it's not even
his success it's his brother's success
his brother's not out here acting like
that his brother is like a nice happily
married man they just had a baby you
know he goes to work every day and comes
home his [__] brother it's like it's
not even about you yeah my God
delusional energy yeah that you could
just do whatever you want to make out
whatever you want good for this girl
like I hope she takes this all the way
yeah for sure it's all on camera he's
literally disgusting
and I'm here for it I'm here for and you
know I mean I was a staunch Defender
I thought people were too mean to
Jacksonville homes but people saw
something on and say yeah just like on
Manor pump rules last night which part
like lala and Katie seeing something
that yeah nobody can say yeah no one
like Ariana like
all right like being so trusting yeah
well like it's almost it's sweet if it
weren't so stupid no like it actually is
bad yeah like it's like Sheena too yeah
like reflecting so poorly on everyone
but you know you really can't blame
someone for wanting to see the good in
people yeah we'll talk about it okay
because I I do feel that way about the
Raquel stuff but like why was she just
like so adamant to like not go after
Sandoval for lying about the Uber at the
Labor Day party yeah she was like kind
of putting that online so like he
literally standing there lying and it's
like so Lala did you get what you wanted
it's like well I was doing this for you
so you could see that your man doesn't
care about you yeah yeah yeah you know
what Ariana's been been she's like you
know she learned she learned but it was
weird to watch and it was making it was
like
it was that that conversation about the
Newport Beach barbecue party was weird
because like lala was trying to point
out inconsistencies and Ariana was like
okay Tom get over here I mean okay Lala
you were right now what yeah it was
weird it's like do so do something about
it right right
I can are you ready for our next story
what do you think I think so okay it's a
little real estate news because
pedophile island has been sold to
billionaire Stephen decoff snaps up dead
pedophile Jeffrey Epstein's two private
islands for 60 million dollars to
develop state-of-the-art luxury resort
that's what I had said that's what I
think when when I I was co-hosting with
Ben maybe during your maternity leave we
were talking about like who's gonna buy
this and Ben was like a Marriott or like
a Four Seasons someone's gonna buy it
because it's cheap at the price because
of what happened there yeah it was
originally listed for 125 million so it
was almost half them half right so
you know what people will forget you
know I'm not going to not stay at this
gorgeous Hotel because the person who
owned it previously was a freak it's a
good business honestly it's a good
business move but who is this guy he's
the founder of private Equity Firm Black
Diamond Capital Management and he has
announced plans to develop a
state-of-the-art luxury 25 room Resort
on the land 25 room oh that's like
really small yeah it's like it's like
it's not a hotel it's like a private
room yeah it's not going to be like yeah
it's like where Sophia Richie Grange
would probably honeymoon oh I found out
where she was honeymooning in the
Maldives yeah but everyone like couldn't
figure it out but then she geotagged it
for a second and accidentally and
removed it the one and only
nice I hadn't heard of it there's one um
in in Cabo that Laura balstic always
goes to that's how I know what it is but
when when celebrities go to the Maldives
they always stay at the Brando or the
Four Seasons like Obama stayed at the
Brando
so I was like why wouldn't the granges
maybe it's new Maybe
maybe
um
um so sorry continue so he owns
BlackRock but Capital Management and so
this is like so like a person didn't buy
it like a company did like the article's
look a little misleading because they're
you know sort of like a venture VC
bought it yeah but it's in his name like
it's not weird yeah
I don't know maybe it's like a personal
investment of his
it's a pretty decent investment I do
think people will eventually
move of course they will where is it
British Virgin Islands or U.S Virgin
Islands British Virgin Islands are much
nicer but like here you wouldn't need a
passport
who doesn't have a passport no like it's
just sometimes like if you can afford to
go to a 25 room you have a [__]
password
okay fine but sometimes it's like nice
to not have to go International for sure
but like if you're staying at this hotel
like you are most likely flying private
and it's like really the same thing
flying private International Customs
versus no Customs there's literally no
Customs like when you fly not to be like
so I'm not just like I have flown
private internationally they literally
like come onto your plane and stamp then
they took a look at you and like give
you a piece of paper and they move on
like it's a five minute thing you could
save those five minutes now that it's US
Virgin Islands five minutes is nothing
to rich people that's what Taylor
schrecker was saying like five times the
only commodity you can't buy
rich people figure it out Tyler Tyler
Taylor strecker was talking about this
thing called stealth wealth
um it's like this new trend it's like
how like really rich people live in an
entirely different world like wearing a
coat like rich people don't wear coats
because like they're never outside you
know and like Customs stealth wealth and
not a thing yeah
these inconveniences yeah no for like
regular people traveling commercial it's
like hours and like years off your life
just to go through customs rich people's
six minutes
okay so passport or no passport right
and I have traveled to both the US and
the British Virgin Islands in one trip
and did you find that one was like uh
yes more convenient oh convenient Beyond
us the beauty of the two it's not even
comparable it's crazy how it's literally
an hour boat ride or like actually what
do we do we flew
it's an hour flight I'm like a time no
not even an hour like it's a 30 minute
flight on one of those tiny planes the
difference like
the British Virgin Islands are so much
more beautiful like it's crazy but it
was so annoying like I couldn't watch
the Harry and Megan interview because I
was in Britain it was when that I was
there when the Oprah interview came out
oh right and I was so excited I had to
get a VPN on my phone oh my God my phone
was like a thousand degrees I was
watching it at the beach I so turned
like literally using like a remote
satellite VPN but I got it it's just so
hard to be like a luxury vacationer like
you who has like a deep obsession with
pop culture yeah it's it's extremely
trying this is me trying
uh would you go here
if I could afford it yeah you wouldn't
if somebody took me if somebody yeah
yeah I'll tell Brian to get on it maybe
they need like you know some hot
influencers to like promote the new
resort when it comes up and I'll
definitely go yeah and it's like you
know what the land didn't do anything no
why are we blaming the land it was the
people yeah no by the way I think like
anyone who wouldn't stay here because of
what used to happen like as like some
sort of being like self-righteous like
that's moronic maybe you would feel a
little weird that I understand but like
oh I would never stay there they used to
own why yeah you're gonna why
like that that stance doesn't do
anything it doesn't except hurt you like
you don't get to go on a beautiful trip
yeah no but it doesn't help the victims
yeah or anything no so just like take
the trip I think honestly like that's
what everyone wants and then maybe find
another way to help the victims to
balance it out because you clearly you
care yeah there should be like a victim
fund yeah where like a portion of the
proceeds yeah like when you're checking
out to book your say it's like do you
want to round up to the nearest Dollar
right or like nearest hundred thousand
dollars right to to help the victims
that's such a good point free idea free
idea but it will cost you
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
State Farm it is the State Farm personal
price plan helps you create a plan that
gives you options so you get an
affordable price and it comes with a lot
of benefits like the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you and an affordable price just for
you because after all life is so much
better when you can personalize your
experiences I mean what's more personal
than insurance
quite literally nothing not food not
poetry
no like Jackie and I name two girls more
similar we have Jackson Claude we are so
similar when I tell you our personal
price plans are so different you're a
homeowner a car owner twice I don't have
much to my name but I still need
insurance you're a renter I'm a renter
like we have different needs and we're
so similar and that's why Insurance
should be personal and it is because
personification no personalization means
you have the power to choose what you
want to include and what you want to
leave out it just feels better that way
and why shouldn't insurance work like
that too that's what the State Farm
personal price plan is all about you can
choose to include options like bundling
your home and auto policies that means
you'll get the coverage you want at an
affordable price just for you in the end
you'll have a policy that gives you what
you want and doesn't that feel better
hmm
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary thank you State
Farm for sponsoring today's episode and
thank you vegamore for sponsoring
today's episode as well we're always
trying to do right by our bodies so when
it comes to our hair and scalp Health
finding a product that actually works is
and is made with clean ingredients
always seems like a trade-off but with
vagamore get products that are made with
clean ingredients and give us visibly
healthy hair and scalp with vegamore we
are able to have visibly thicker fuller
and shinier hair without all the harsh
ingredients all vegamore products are
100 cruelty free and are never
formulated with potentially harmful
chemicals like parabens or hormones so
everybody knows like I'm dealing with
this issue and I'm like trying all
different things I've you know recently
started shedding my hair I was
literally like freaking out about it a
few weeks ago you're in like your
pregnant clean girl era so we both have
like different needs different reasons
to come to the same product right so
vagamore's value kits like the the grow
Essentials kit which is what Jackie and
I both use you get to try more than one
amazing product and they also have great
savings when you sign up for a monthly
subscription you save more and you never
run low on products that you need to
take care of your hair the key with your
hair care routine is consistency if you
want the most beautiful healthy looking
hair that's why we use vegamore hair the
grow hair serum we use it daily on our
hair and scalp and we're flourishing fun
fact vegamore sells one bottle of gross
serum every 15 seconds on their website
it's really popular for a reason that's
how good it is give yourself the hair
you never thought you could have with
vegamore for a limited time the toast
listeners get 20 off their first order
by going to vegamore.com toast and use
code toast I have seen definite results
and honestly I feel like such a the
hardest part about like going through
like hair shedding or thinning whatever
you're going through is like feeling so
helpless and like once you just start
actively using Vega more like it feels
it's such a weight off your chest
process and you're like you're doing
something about it like just if it's
been bothering you like get started
because it will feel better trust the
process also vegamore is perfect for me
because it's clean but it also promotes
growth like I still am in my regrowth
but I want to use clean products Vega
more
you ready for our next story I am
Priyanka Chopra was on Howard Stern and
she's opening up about her botched nose
job and how she fell into a deep deep
depression over it Howard Stern's Making
Waves this month he is
Priyanka Chopra says she fell into a
deep deep depression after a botched
nose procedure and thought her career in
entertainment was totally over she made
the revelations during an interview with
Howard Stern on his show going into
detail about the dark period earlier in
her life she told Howard that a
physician recommended that she go under
the knife to remove a polyp in her nasal
cavity she followed the doctor's
instructions and got the nose job but
afterwards she says her face looked
completely different causing her to slip
into a deep deep depression not only did
the surgery affect her physical
appearance but it negatively impacted
her work she was said she was fired from
three films as a result of the bungle
procedure making her think that her
career was over before it started she
says things got so bad that she didn't
even want to leave her house at times
but her late father who was a doctor as
well convinced her to get corrective
surgery despite her misgivings so he
went and was in the room with her and
holding her hand and helped her build
back her confidence she says she got her
career back on track with the help of
Bollywood director Anil Sharma and was
grateful to him for giving her a
supporting role in a movie even though
she was originally slated to play the
lead she then went on to start in
several major Hollywood TV serieses
including Citadel and Quantico yeah
Quantico like really put her on the map
yeah so but in America this was like
very early in her career and here are
three photos of oh the nose
I don't really know what I'm looking at
like like I think um I think after the
Box knows job like it still looks pretty
fine it looks really good but it clearly
changed her face and she had gotten
famous like yeah with one face and this
has happened before to celebrities like
you go in for like a little tweak or a
change and it's like it changes your
whole face that's what happened to um
Chloe no no but Chloe's not it wasn't a
tweak but Chloe got to a place where
like but Chloe's famous for like being
Chloe no Jennifer Gray from Dirty
Dancing that's like the famous story and
then you know she was in the biggest
movie and then she changed her face and
then she wasn't in the biggest movies
anymore right right I have like a hot
take on the story and I don't know if I
should just shut up because it's kind of
mean
is it like a tiny violins playing it's
tiny violins but it's also like I don't
know I feel like this is like somebody's
attempt to be like authentic and raw and
it's like not sad like oh you got a bad
nose job in your daddy doctor like
brought you back to yet another one like
okay like I feel like there's actually a
lot of parts of priyanka's life that I
don't know about that are immensely
interesting like I would love to know
like all about Bollywood and how she
made the transition like I don't know I
just felt like she wanted to endear
herself to people like this story is
just like not cutting it for me like
that's your dark time like your nose job
like I don't know I've never gotten a
nose shot and maybe it's like really
traumatic to have I don't know I'm just
like okay yes I hear what you're saying
but then like to this is like just
because knowing that this has happened
like a few times where it changes your
face then like you lose out on three
rolls like you regret so wholeheartedly
this thing that you've done I'm sure it
sent her into a dark time and you know
the worst time in someone's life is the
worst time in their life yeah it's the
worst thing that they've ever been
you're right you're right I'm being mean
no and it's like maybe it's not the
worst thing of all time but it's still
the hardest thing that they've ever had
to go through but I do completely
[__] see your point and I also like
just no I'm sure honestly Priyanka
Chopra like has been through a lot of
stuff like like any person has and like
I don't know this is like her vulnerable
moment I'm just like having a hard time
being like Oh my God I also feel like
her saying that she went under to remove
the polyp in her nasal cavity like she
could also just say like I got a nose I
wanted a nose job yeah people it's
getting like deviated
but no I actually really did have a
deviated I'm sure you did but again if
you liked how it looked you wouldn't
have touched it and by the way you can
get deviated septum surgery and polyp
surgery without changing the shape of
your nose at all Ben got like the sinus
deviated septum surgery and his nose is
exactly the same right because Ben loves
his nose he never wanted to change it he
was that's what he he almost put off the
surgery for years because he thought he
had to like you don't have to so when
people say that like shut the [__] up
[__] all this to say I didn't watch the
whole interview maybe that was maybe she
said that and it's not in this article
and maybe this article is just making
her come off as like inauthentic because
this is just giving like very woe is me
like maybe if I watch the interview it
would endear me to her more
I feel like it would I feel like you
know having a period of especially as a
young aspiring act just having a period
where they're kind of like
on the outs and you did it to yourself
and it's like because of your physical
appearance and yeah and it's like a
choice that you need like I I imagine
that's really hard to go through as a
young woman like I don't think that this
was not nothing but I understand why
you're saying that it's it's giving like
hey look at me yeah hey feel sorry for
me yeah
no it's just getting like a like it
feels like so out of touch like
I don't know
she's just talking like I know I like
hate I hate to like I hate to be this
person that's why I almost didn't say it
I'm sure it's a very long interview I'm
sure this was like the thing that a lot
of Publications found the most
interesting yeah people love talking
about plastic surgery so I'm not gonna
like be like you know Bianca Chopra sat
down to talk about her nose right right
she's like writing a girl she was just
sharing and like we're choosing to read
this and like you're allowed to share
and you are you have to like break the
internet every time it has it doesn't
have to be the saddest thing I ever
heard yeah
I guess
everyone has their own personal internal
struggles and I just I didn't know that
about her I didn't know that about her
either let's just leave it at that
okay
it's left yeah why'd you put the iPad
tell me another story because we were
leaving it at that yeah no so it was
giving like conclusive energy like of
the episode now the episode's over but
there was something I wanted to say on
the toast yesterday that I totally
forgot okay
and then I remembered it as I was like
falling asleep I'm like
was it about the Met Gala
Maybe
I can't remember
okay it's like it's gonna come to me
later like
wait oh you know we haven't spoken about
the writer strike Oh I thought you were
gonna say Draft Day Draft day two I've
been getting so many tick tocks of like
emotional videos of people getting their
phone calls from the coaches I [__]
love videos like that that's like
military reunions I love I actually
watched a lot of the draft because Zach
was insistent that we watched and so I
got to see all of the Fanfare yeah it's
so sweet it's such an exciting day but
the writer strike is like a really big
deal so Pete Davidson's SNL episode he
was supposed to host on Saturday he was
supposed to host yes he was supposed to
come back the episodes canceled the
writers are on strike and I believe it's
an NBC thing so it's like for peacock
writers want to be there they want to um
like adjust their the terms of their
contracts because with streaming like
all their [__] is getting like so much
bigger and and they want to be paid
accordingly and people are like holding
out but at the mecca like everyone was
asked about it and like everyone is
being No One's Gonna Be Like I am
against the writer's Union no one will
ever write a good haters no one will
ever write a good role for them but
Amanda Seyfried gave like the weirdest
thing like she obviously just didn't
know what was going on in 65 and you
don't know I have to know everything
about everything and she was like yeah
like it's [__] like just like
like help the writers like her interview
was so cringe and like there are some
people especially like John Mulaney and
Jimmy Fallon who like were at one point
writers they know a lot about it so
they're like really educated Rob Lowe is
you know it's giving very much like PR
moment but he's out there with he's
doing something he's out there with the
picket ers Amanda Seyfried is like with
her full Glam like it's just [__]
right man like she sounded high like so
[__] like I don't get it like just
come on
give them she didn't even know like what
they were asking for I kind of love that
yeah no she's like I support I don't
know anything about it but I'm with the
writers yeah yeah that's really funny
but do you remember the writer strike
when we were kids Desperate Housewives
all of our favorite shows were impacted
oh my God it was so annoying we were
like come on writers we were so mad we
were so mad it was like oh no our
favorite Show's not on next because
there's a writer strike right and this
is where it really kind of pays to be a
big fan of reality television because
there are no writers that's true or like
binge-watching shows and it's not like
we're you're waiting for the next
episode but when we the last writer
strike which I believe like when we were
in like Middle School we lasted a really
long time like how long does this last I
don't know it's like that episode of 30
Rock I feel like Amanda Seyfried like I
don't know what about it I know Adam
just come on man what I know about it I
know from the episode of 30 Rock how's
the writer Jack is negotiating with
Kenneth and he just wants like you know
a dollar an hour and jack won't give it
to him but that's what I know about this
but I'm just wondering what it means for
us like as viewers like I do believe if
it goes on for a certain amount yeah
very interesting are you ready for our
fifth and final story I am it's a very
exciting story because it's brought to
you by the MTV movie and TV Awards
because the MTV movie and TV Awards are
back I know I saw a commercial for them
yesterday and I was shook that Drew
Barrymore yeah is the host they got a
A-list host live Sunday at 8 7 Central
and hosted by the one and only Drew
Barrymore who is just like the host du
jour these days no do you think that
Drew Barrymore is gonna like with every
person who wins I go up and like touch
eyeballs and kiss them oh that's the
thing about her yeah she like can't stop
touching people honestly covet was
probably really hard for her
it's the biggest night to be a fan and
for good reason it's an award show that
honors the movies and TV shows we
actually watch true so true like not us
going through like all the other award
shows being like the nominees and like
we've never heard of half of these
things literally we're gonna get to the
nominees and we've seen all the movies
and what I like about this award show is
like everybody really shows up because
it's just fun it's fun it's not like so
serious and the awards are chosen by the
fans and I do think that means the most
to most of the artists I agree so the
awards are chosen and voted on by the
fans and some of the categories and
nominees include best movie you want to
place our votes yeah okay read me the
nominees Avatar the way of water oh
that's like it's so hard to be up
against Avatar it is Black Panther
wakanda forever also hard to be up
against black panther Elvis oh nope
Oh I thought you were like I thought you
were like Elvis nope no no no no no no
Scream Six
smile top gun Maverick
all right maybe we'll get like another
Sydney Sweeney Glenn Powell red carpet
moment
because how will my chill up and like
but why would she be there because like
they're allegedly dating no but they're
not gonna give it away so fast maybe
they will for the MTV TV and movie but
she did post a picture to her Instagram
about their movie got a release date in
December and it's like a picture of her
and Glenn in the article no I'm telling
you yeah something is up okay best show
stranger things okay The Last of Us the
White Lotus oh wait we didn't give a
vote for the first time oh I think
Avatar like I don't know how you go up
against Avatar and lose yeah
Black Panther
Avatar black panther okay now best show
stranger things The Last of Us the White
Lotus Wednesday wolf pack Yellow Jackets
Yellowstone yellow do you think like the
cast of things are so weird with
Yellowstone I feel like no one they
don't want to walk any carpets because
they're just going to be asked like
what's going on yeah and I think they're
filming so and I feel like yeah like not
one of them will show up I do think um
White Lotus will win one because it
really was like the TV show of the year
and two because Jennifer Coolidge is
being honored with a Comedy Award yes
she's getting the comedic genius award
so it would just be like a great night
for Jennifer Coolidge if she could win
all of them oh I think and she'll be
there to accept a good very good point
I'm surprised she wasn't at the Met Gala
oh my God yeah I was thinking about that
it's weird well it wasn't for lack of
Invitation movie and TV Awards they
respect they respect I think that the
last of us might win because everybody
is talking about that show I know and I
didn't watch it and I feel like such
like I feel so out of the loop I know
but I also don't think that I should
like I just don't think it's a show for
me but your queen from Game of Thrones
is in it Bella Ramsay yeah yeah I know
it's hard was she a Ramsay in the show
no she was a northerner though oh okay
because it's giving Ramsay Bolton energy
it is also everyone's favorite category
the most iconic category the kiss best
kiss so we have Anna Torv and infected
in The Last of Us Harry Styles and David
Dawson in my policeman Madison Bailey
and Rudy pankow in Outer Banks oh I just
watched oh actually I like that yeah
Riley Keough and Sam Claflin from Daisy
Jones and the six no nope and Selena and
Cara Delevingne only murders in the
building that wasn't like a really great
kiss it was kind of weird and like soft
I'm kind of rooting for Outer Banks me
too because honestly I didn't even
realize when I was watching the show how
much I shipped them until like the show
because it really was was like for her
and Pope yeah but until like the show
changed my mind I was so here for her
and JJ
and it actually it was a really good
kiss too yeah when did they kiss
on the boat no they almost he broke out
of Camp no
yeah yeah yeah
I love JJ yeah no they're really really
cute that's my selection as well also
there's just gonna be a ton of silences
from celebs it'll be star studded Jamie
Lee Curtis Tiffany haddish Gal Gadot
Halle Gary Anthony Ramos she's Sarah
Michelle Geller the cast of Vanderpump
Rules the cast of Yellowjackets so many
the cast of Anna from girls I feel like
every year for this award show like they
always show up and show out like it's
really glamorous but this year more than
ever but like do Raquel and Tom go
together right
um they should I feel like rocket I feel
like this always like it it always lines
up that this award show is like at the
either the very end of Venom pump rules
or right after it ends and it's like a
nice way to like conclude the season and
they all dress up and like look really
great but now like there's so much more
I feel like and what if Ariana brings
her new man's Kristen was talking about
it last night yeah but she has a new man
and that he's lovely yeah so this you're
not going to want to miss the MTV movie
and TV Awards which are Sunday live at
eight seven Central it's the biggest
night to be a fan don't miss the 2023
MTV movie and TV Awards hosted by Drew
Barrymore live Sunday at 8 7 Central
watch on MTV all right let's do TV recap
speaking of inner pump rules we were
just speaking of TV Awards Vanderpump
Rules last night's episode of interpret
rules I did misspeak the the finale of
inner prep rules I wasn't entirely wrong
because I said yesterday it airs May
17th so I think there's
two more episodes yeah how do weeks work
I don't know it's the fourth so then the
11th then two more
but the finale is the 17th yes so one
more before the finale run more before
the finale and it definitely feels that
way like things are coming to a head yes
so last night okay but I also feel like
this line that they gave us that nothing
has been edited since scandival broke is
a lot I think so too there's so many
scenes where they're like punching in on
Santa ball when Raquel is speaking that
there's no way we're there before okay
let's talk about glamping because first
of all there was no glue in that amping
it was full-on camping
it looked horrible
weird crew weird crew and weirdness
about like the gift like was so weird
like first of all who give someone a
pair of sunglasses without a case
I thought that was weird like he pulled
these like sunglasses that have been
like chilling in his pocket and probably
like all scratched up and he was like
giving it to her just like like it meant
so much and it was just weird and it was
just like Raquel was so emotional the
whole time it made me feel like maybe
she's drunk drunk they were all drunk I
feel like she was maybe like higher like
took mushrooms they were all under the
influence I mean not I don't not
everyone but she's going to bed crying
with the sunglasses on oh I must have
been on my phone
um when she's giving like her toes which
by the way she finally learned how to
like do a toast everyone's being like so
mushy even when they're sitting around
like you can just tell they're just
being drunk or high or whatever yeah so
emo take that with a grain of salt but
still like that's how they were behaving
yeah and like all the weird speeches
about like her wanting you know pageants
were so stifling for her and she started
crying when she was like you know I was
supposed to be an occupational therapist
and I'm like why are we crying no and
she was like with pageants you have to
have your career planned out so at a
young age she chose to be an
occupational therapist and like and
since then it just felt like her life
was mad opt out before her it sounds
like she's talk like she sounds like
Queen Elizabeth and she's had this like
you know Duty that she has to uphold
it's like okay girl like then don't be
an occupational therapist right and then
she like and this part she's not drunk
because she's in her confessionals she's
like crying again about her she's just
like desperate to be a good role model
and it was just like it was all too much
it was so yikes it was so it was and it
was so weird when she was like I don't
know what I'm doing with my life like
and my parents like are like what are
you doing and they were like well what
about pageants nobody's like what about
the elephant in the room you're
literally a famous reality star like
it's good yeah no but when she two
seasons ago she said she like was not
gonna be on the show anymore and she was
gonna go back to like doing the work
that she um was doing wanted to do and I
thought that was like really respectable
so I'm sure her parents are like what
happened to you but I also think she's
going through a crisis and I think
that's what they're saying and she like
knows that she is but doesn't know how
to get out of it so she sleeps with Tom
Sandoval right right she must have been
in a major crisis because he's just
getting weirder and weirder looking like
with his outfits and his mom hair and I
just can't [__] stand him and
honestly like in last week and this week
he's getting like caught in the lie so
the editing at the beginning of the
episode I actually thought I saw a lot
of people being like this is confusing I
found it to be really helpful like it
was a full-blown timeline of how
everything found out but oh my God Ken
Vanderpump Todd with his rehearsed line
like Lisa found something out and Lisa
is a producer of this show and she
wanted to it to be on camera and she
found it out I guess off camera no she
found out
so why did she clearly make Ken come
into the kitchen and be like
can you believe Raquel slept at Tom
Sandoval's house like it was so scripted
oh I didn't think that I feel like Lisa
would have brought it up regardless
regardless because he was also on camera
like the table he was like how about
that Raquel sleeping at Tom Sandoval I
love that for him yeah
yeah
um so I found the editing to be like
helpful like how the game of telephone
actually started everyone was coming to
things like on their own like that James
and Lala conversation had nothing to do
with what Lisa Vanderpump like had
already found out and make thus making
it even more weird yeah but Lala got her
information from Katie right James
already knew from Tom Sandoval and Brock
conversation and it's like they clearly
had something to hide yeah so I don't
know why they didn't get their story
more straight like Tom Sandoval being
like she dipped
oh my God if he says dipped again and
what's so oh my God he's so annoying
he's like dude she dipped I'm like shut
up what does that mean calling Lisa dude
and by the way saying someone dipped
means that they left yep okay but in Tom
Sandoval's work he was saying she left
and got went to a different room so no
in Tom Sandoval's World it means that
she did she went to sleep that's what
that's not what it means though but
that's not what I mean later in the show
when he's I think when he's talking
about the Labor Day party he said like
Jason dipped
so Jason left right so what the [__]
does dipped mean in your world right you
got it [__] annoying piece of [__]
you got him so
she got him like use words that's why we
have language the English language is
beautiful and there's really otherwise
we're just like a Tower of Babel people
talking not understanding there is a
word for everything dalliance there's a
word for everything did she go to sleep
was it acrimonious did she leave so that
hosago just like was bad also Raquel
said she slept on the couch then Tom
Sandoval she was in the guest room in my
bed the guest bed in my bed the guest
bed yeah and The Way Ariana is like so
unbothered by all of this is suspicious
it's suspicious and of course like I'm T
Mariana like but I'm just reacting to
the things that I'm seeing of course and
I I don't understand why why she's being
this way like I don't yeah like even in
the most trusting relationships like
weird is weird weird is weird weird is
weird Everybody that keeps posting this
question like would you trust your
partner like to sleep in the same bed as
your best friend and some people are
like yeah because I like it depends like
I trust my partner I trust my friend no
to sleep in a bed and not do anything
with another woman yes is in any [__]
world that even remotely [__] okay no
and throats will be slipped and wound up
like crashing in a bed with one of your
friends yeah I trust that nothing would
happen same but the act itself is so
inappropriate there must be consequences
and it makes me question this person who
I thought I knew there must and like
okay maybe you guys were so drunk you
just like fell into sleeping into the
same bed then you have to then you have
to start monitoring your drinking that
only circumstance where that's okay is
that Ben and a friend of mine have been
abducted and thrown in a room with one
bed and honestly even then Ben should
sleep on the floor if it's a girl give
the girl the bed yeah and you know Ben
is bad back and actually why were they
abducted together
what were they doing
it's so like Andy asked Annalee Ashley
she was like yeah I would trust but not
Raquel not Tom Sandra right right no no
no like it's not about trust it's just
about like weird boundaries and like
things don't happen a hundred percent I
think something shouldn't happen right
so nothing's happening the lunch event
it was very nice for Bravo to air
Christina Kelly's fake beauty company
that was really sweet it was a nice
event it actually was classy like
everyone like just looked really nice
and respectful and and it was just a
nice I don't know it wasn't like packed
it felt like weird and almost unfair
that Katie had her mom there because
like no one was gonna get into it with
Katie with her mom sitting right next to
her so like everyone just like walked
away from her yeah but you know I don't
need Katie to get into with anyone like
she said what she needed to say she's
completely right she see she sees
through everyone yeah the only
conversation that needed to be had was
Katie and Ariana I thought Katie handled
herself so well and made really good
points I don't feel like Katie
insinuated that they have an open
relationship I feel like that's what Ali
heard but you know sometimes someone
says something and what you process is
completely different yeah and they're
that's just like not what they meant at
all I think Katie was saying like
they just have a different sort of
relationship by the way what we're
seeing play out like all this weird
stuff happening and Ariana not caring
about the barbecue about Raquel sleeping
they do have like no rules right she's
100 right and like if if Ariana is a
homebody and Tom likes to go out it's
not like she has a rule like you need to
be home by 1am like they don't have
rules and that's just their relationship
right Ali heard that as open
relationship I don't think Katie said
anything wrong or anything untrue I
really like Ally I really like her too I
have to say last week when James like
thought he got that 150 proof alcohol in
his eye he's like oh alley and oh my God
that I made Ben watch because when we
were um waiting for last night's episode
to air like the last 20 minutes of the
previous weeks we're on and I'm like Ben
you have to watch this it's the funniest
thing that whole Saga where James then
runs to the bathroom and falls and ends
up just being water in the in the cup
was the fun it was literally like you
couldn't write comedy so funny that's
funny it was the best thing ever and
Ally was just so funny about it like not
giving a [__] she's like shut up yeah I
really like her I hope that James can be
worthy of her I know he's like the worst
and you know obviously the season is
highlighting the worst and Tom and and
Raquel and we're all focusing on that
and James is so funny but like it's so
important to remember like how he
literally was the worst like literally
Raquel told us this season that she had
to break up with him because he
literally called her mom fat like he's
the [__] worst but like it's just so
hard not to be obsessed with everything
that comes out of his mouth yeah and
just not to want to like start a new
every day it's tabulous every episode
like what James are we gonna get the
last few episodes we've gotten like good
James yeah he really should stop
drinking yeah and like he does he kind
of reminds me and way how you were
pointing out her like Tom Sandoval every
10 years like he's in a relationship and
then sees like a young new girl who he
can mold and he'll be with her until he
gets tired of her and she gets old and
I'll go find someone else it like James
reminds me a little bit of that like he
always chooses these like younger timid
girls and and that was so Raquel and it
worked until it didn't but there's
something about ali like she really does
stand up for herself I feel like he
thought that's what he was getting with
Ali yeah and he actually got
um someone who is a very strong whale
strong and a good match for him if he
can rise to the occasion right and not
be like put off by the fact that she's
not just like subservient but he seems
like he's fine with it they don't like
when she stands up for herself like
that's that's the end of the story the
conversation because when he got that
thing in his eye and he came back he was
like you didn't even care she's like
yeah I don't care sit down and shut up
that's what she said to him right and
then she's like you look stupid sit down
and shut up and I feel like like Raquel
had ever would never but if she did he
would be like are you kidding bloody
hell right and I feel like he kind of
likes I just hope I really do
accidentally got into the right
relationship for him yeah but he might
[__] it up because like that's what he
does and Everyone likes Everyone likes
Alex the cool girls like Ali Ariana
likes out like Everyone likes Alex
you're like lala Katie Christina yeah I
wouldn't call Christina like cool girl
but they're like especially after the
glamping like yeah I was watching
exactly I was like a bigger group of
losers I've never seen and then you like
cut to all these like women in business
I'm just like having their [__] together
I'm like that's the cool group yeah no
like this episode it changes week two it
changes week to week like Vegas they
were not being the cool girls they were
being the Mean Girls yeah yeah yeah
I found this episode like so crazy there
was just so like every scene had a
million things to unpack a million body
language
facial reactions so much and the whole
barbecue thing was so weird and we've
been I've been hearing about this
alleged barbecue in like you know blogs
and Jax talked about it on watch Robin's
live right so now knowing actually like
timeline wise Labor Day the day Ariana
found out her grandmother had passed
away and his ride left and he didn't go
and like I'm sorry where are you that
you can't get an Uber I'm sorry like in
this day and age there's no excuse to
not be able to get a ride home
yeah no and he had a ride home and he
let the ride leave even though Ariana
like said that she needed him and then
he admitted that the market Jason left
and and he had I guess told Ariana I was
taking a [__] and Jason left and he's
such a [__] liar and I do have like a
little blame for Ariana for not like
holding his feet to the fire at all and
instead like being like okay Lala is
that what you wanted are you happy it's
like no are you happy yeah
like she's really being like blindly
loyal to a fault like I don't find it
commendable like I feel like she's just
burying her head in the sand maybe
because at this point like what we know
about their relationship is like they
were both like really like maybe she
just stopped caring but then she in her
confessional she's like crying because
she's like Tom's biggest fan and he
doesn't feel that way about her yeah she
loves him so much and I believed her
when yeah that was really sad but she's
also like a a smart girl so like when
you see one plus one is equaling sock
you gotta do something about it you
gotta question the sock of course like
none of this is her fault whatsoever
it's just like her reactions I found to
be surprising yeah like surprisingly
like low energy yeah when there's like
clear crime yes being committed yeah
so I guess next week is the last episode
before the finale don't quote me on that
and that's our show yeah that is it
thank you one thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast the Monday
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories you need to know everybody
the Friday on YouTube so for watching
this on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available podcast anywhere
podcasting be found on Spotify
beautiful stunning and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have a great day
tomorrow's episode is Audio Only and
then we're back in studio on Monday for
a full errors recap but we'll see you
tomorrow morning love ya bye